περνάκριση το αυτόα σο δημοκατικός σδσήμερα όχι συναιεπικοδομητική μεχρι τώρα η ατιπορίτευση ποασκία η προσπάθεια
μας είναι ακριβώς να βελτιωθεί εκείνο το θέμα το οποίο να γύρουμε μου π πέτε
πράματα που διαφωνεί ο δημοκαικός συναγερμόμε εν κυβέρνηση και γι αυτόένα αντι πολύτεύηση πορίσε ότιικόνασήμεραδού
μου κατικού συναγερμού αστενοχωρούσαν των οράμιωιανίοσίγουρα θααστροφορ τι ότι όντω και ο παντέρα το ήταν
νας άνθρωπος ο οποις τάσαμε στην περίοδον όπου αντίπαλος ξεσαικά πάντα είναι το ελά αντίπαλος
του δημοκρατικού συναγερμού ήταν είναι και θα είναι ολακισόικόνα πο έχεισα σύ θεωρείς όο κάποιοι
περιμένω της τη γωνιά δεν παεικαλά τοπος η έξι η θέση του προεδρομοναχική πάμε και
ο πολιτικά τι σε αν ησέχει περισσότεμη τογαό ναθησάμου υπάρχουν τριασυνάρ ου μιχάλησε ο ανίτης
θα έχει περισσότελενω πλοκι το επόμενοδιάστημα στεμογατιό σναγεμο ο έναση του τη π ο κτός
απόάνθρωπος κια θα βρεθει στην εγιατική πυραμδαθε οτορώς κιά θελιφώςκύρες και φίλες σας χαιρετώ ανλό
έναντε ένα λάεα σημερα μαζείς ς εδώ καλεσμένος ο μηχάλησε ο ανίδης ο άνθρωπος όπως
τον λέγοσκιά ο άνθρωπος ο συντονιστής του σκεότες υπουργικού δημοκρατικού συναγερμού και νομικός μιχάλησε ευχαριστώ
πολύ που αποδέχθηκε στην πρόσκλησή μου θσιάου ίσε ευχαριστώ παραπολύα την πρόσκληση κάρχή και για
δα καλάσου όχι ξεγινό ποιο υνομηχάλη σημανίδης έτσι για να ναμάθηκε ο κόσμος που μπορεί
να μηγνωρίζε είμαι ένας δικηγώρος από τοχι κνιακόσεντανι ποδόχι για νια όσανντανιάντα κτών ηντνιά για
πολλά χρόνια ασχολούμομε δικιγορία σε διάφορος τομίς ασχολιθεία μεταχρηματα οικονομικά θέματα δικαστηριώ στη συνέχεια